hai curato il culo a quella ora
veramente non ho parole calogero mai
visto come mi ha portato quello mi ha
mangiato con gli occhi certo non l'hai
visto perché gli occhi stava solo per
guardare le altre maiale o e teso tutto
bene tu come andata l'anno di grafica
tutto bene ma che poi voglio dire ma se
ti piacciono quelle con le tette grosse
ma perché ti sei messo con me non
essendo mai capito il bar ci vado io
l'ho visto benissimo che c'è la tua ex
dallo zero ringraziare stava in mezzo
alla gente che sta veramente facendo
incazzare no poi a casa vedi bella
quella cioè tutta arrivata e station
cose quando e se avesse come ti
piacevano le le le ragazze semplici gli
piacevo perché ero semplice con ti
piacciono sti cosi maturo sede se una
cosa non l'hanno assi muore ma sei scemo
io sono la rosa isola rosa tu non mi
annaffia e muoio cioè non sai neanche
capire le poesie o se propio ignorante
si sia arrivano anche noi a fare il
bagno preciso la guardare il culo su
prova e si